[Music]
welcome to our different room for
session number 16 of philosophers in the
midst of history this is a series that
we've been doing hosted here at the
Frank Weinberg library for three years
now and we're hopefully gonna be
scheduling another fourth year of it
coming up soon we start out with a
author from ancient philosophy and we
talk about their historical context and
the contributions that they made to you
know history itself during the spring
and then in the summer we do somebody
from the medieval period then in the
fall we do somebody early modern and
then in the the winter which we're now
officially in since we have snow falling
outside we do somebody late modern
usually 20th century although we did do
Nietzsche one time so nineteen late 19th
century early 20th century and today
we're doing somebody who I'm a big fan
of and that's Simone de Beauvoir and
what I'd like to say first about her
before I talk a little bit about you
know what we usually do in the session
is that she in recent years has started
to become recognized as importance in
philosophy on her own account all too
often in the past I think because you
know she was so closely associated with
jean-paul Sartre and because of some of
the very issues that they have to do
with you know gender and men and women
and and you know things that feminists
were critiques of the things she
diagnosed in her second sex she was
often looked at was like being Sartre
sidekick or his helper his muse or
things like that and her Falah you know
she wrote great novels and she wrote
this you know ethics of ambiguity that's
kind of cool to take a look at if you've
got extra time when you're studying the
existentialist Sartre is the real big
thing and I think people have come to
recognize now that no that's not the
case at all and it wasn't just because
she also wrote you know a big thick book
of her own the sec
Saxe which which has been incredibly
important in feminist circles but people
now recognize that her her philosophical
work is really you know just as good and
just as important as that of jean-paul
Sartre and that there's a lot of
philosophy straight-out philosophy in
things like the second sex or her essay
on desaad or and in her her novels so I
think that's that's kind of a cool thing
there's a new biography of her out now
which I was reading a little bit of an
interview with the the author of it and
the the author was getting criticized
for not talking much about Sartre and
she replied hasn't there been enough of
that I thought that you know that story
is pretty clear let's actually focus on
undo before so it's impossible not to
talk about Sartre which we're going to
do but I think it is important to
recognize her importance as a thinker
really of the first rank in her own
right and as somebody who straddles a
couple different fences you know in in
terms of feminism she is one of the most
important voices of what they have come
to call second wave feminism but in the
existentialist movement she's you know
just as important as Friedrich Nietzsche
or certain Kierkegaard or Albert Camus
or jean-paul Sartre or Martin Heidegger
I think she's just as important as all
of those figures so generally what we do
in these and you can feel free to
interrupt me at any point to ask
questions if you want to what I do is I
present the the life of the person and
talk a bit about their their works and
the idea is to situate them within the
history that they they lived in you know
philosophy doesn't get done in a vacuum
it's you know the things that people are
focusing on are are products of what the
larger culture is concerned with or
massive events in in de Beauvoir case
there's a lot of you know kind
quirky contingent things that affect her
life that are quite central and
important and her philosophy can take
account of that so we want to talk about
that and then I'll talk about some of
her key ideas as well from some of her
works and then I like to talk a little
bit about how she ended up contributing
to history and I think that that's still
an ongoing project you could say maybe
project isn't the right word
and she's still exerting effects through
history right now so you know she gets
brought up during discussions of the me
to movement for example which is you
know very recent this this whole sort of
activist focus on bringing to light all
the terrible things that people have
been doing and which have been covered
up or stuffed down for years and years
within within a forum primarily Twitter
at first where people could actually
bring their stories out and be believed
and have some solidarity on that sort of
thing so let's talk about her life she's
born I get everybody a little timeline
here she's born in 1908 born in Paris
it's salt
her father was this this legal secretary
George Bert bertrand de Beauvoir and he
had aspirations of being an actor her
mother was a very different sort
francois x' brosser originally and then
you know she takes the Beauvoir name she
was a wealthy bankers daughter and a
devout Catholic and Simone de Beauvoir
later talks about in in this memoir that
she writes called the memoirs of a
dutiful daughter did a little bit of
self-promotion there I guess she says
she talks about her father's
individualism and Pagan ethical
standards you know so in a way it's sort
of like Augustine right Augustine has
got a pagan dad and a devout Catholic
mother
to prove wires have got kind of a
similar thing any and and she says that
it was in complete contrast to the
rigidly moral conventionalism of my
mother's teaching and and she said that
that actually contributed to her
becoming an intellectual there was you
know when you have if everybody believes
the same thing you don't really need to
think right you just kind of learn it
and then follow along and when you screw
up just see what everybody else does and
kind of follow along that path and you
won't screw up anymore but when you've
got real clashes over central issues
like you know is it important to care
what the neighbors think or should you
go to church every every weekend or you
know sleep in or does God exist or are
those sorts of things and and people
that you you see in your household take
different positions then that that well
for some people that that leads to
neuroses right but for others it can
lead to saying well there must be
something going on here these people
seem to be reasonable and yet they don't
agree how can I figure out some some
solutions myself so she says that that
played a an important role in her
becoming an intellectual she calls it a
disequilibrium which made my life kind
of an endless disputation which is nice
nice turn of phrase now she she winds up
in in her family rather fun winds up in
financial difficulties after the war you
know World War one took an incredible
toll not just on the population of
France you know a whole generation of
young men many of them died on the the
Western Front and you know that's part
of what led to the transformation of a
French culture but there were also a lot
of economic dust dislocations and her
family seems to have suffered from that
as well and you know in a way it led
it's not good that they suffered that
way but it led to even more you could
say thing factors
that freed her from from the
expectations of the culture that she was
growing up in one of the big
expectations is that a girl should have
a dowry this is even for people who are
you know thinking that they were they
were nonconformist well they still like
money and having a dowry was quite
important there were there wasn't any
possibility of that so that led to her
not being able to to marry and she
decided to go off and pursue work
instead and study and be independent
whereas you know she might have been
tempted had that her family been more
well-off or whether the the economic
downturns better she might have had a
more conventional life so she decides to
go off and study philosophy she passes
the baccalaureate for mathematics and
philosophy studies mathematics at the
Institute Catholic and literature and
languages at the on stitute sont memory
and then she goes to live with her
grandmother in 1926 and starts studying
philosophy and literature at the
Sorbonne within a few years she
graduates she has a thesis on live knits
and now she's sort of like moving up
right in the French you know we think of
like well you go to your high school and
then you know college and then maybe you
go on and get your your PhD or something
like that or probably you're done and
you go on to professional life or maybe
you go on and do a professional school
well you know the French system is very
hierarchical and and there's some very
orderly steps even even still today but
even more back then so she starts going
to the Ecole Normale now this is sort of
like the big big time and there she
meets jean-paul Sartre and they've you
know fallen off he actually does propose
at that time but she has to reveal that
she has no dowry and you know it's not
really gonna be feasible for them and
they begin this relationship that we'll
talk a little bit more
about that's quite controversial and and
there's you know a lot of different
interpretations of what was going on
with them but it's a relationship that
lasts their entire life you know she's
there when he dies there are a lot of
coming and goings I think you could say
in in their relationship that's maybe a
good way to summarize it but they were
the two central pillars kind of funny
I'll just say this and then I want to
get back to talking about her studies so
we usually think of a relationship is
you know primarily a couple right they
did a lot of triangles and so you've got
two pillars that are you know always
there and then there's usually like a
third pillar of some sort but it's a
pillar you can swap in and out but maybe
it needed to be there for the kind of
relationship that they were having if we
want to use some architectural that of
course so in any case she's going and
she's studying and she should you know
in in a interview that she gave in 1965
she actually said my studies gave me
only a superficial knowledge of
philosophy which is not surprising given
the way that philosophy is being taught
at the time but sharpened my interest in
it and then she later on would go on and
start teaching she starts teaching at
these lis saves and at least a is
basically like a high school but it's
different than our high schools in our
you know culture the American system
right whatever we have that that's a
system we don't generally do philosophy
in high school if we do it's um it might
be smuggled in like in a social studies
section or you know maybe if they're
doing a biology class they might get
into some philosophical topics like what
is life or things like that but we don't
we don't usually have whole classes on
it unless unless it's taught as an
English elective or or social studies
elective in a well-heeled private school
or it's taught usually is a religion
elective
catholic and sometimes other christian
schools as well but it's kind of a
strange thing to encounter right in the
french system you study philosophy
there's no option you have to pass a
philosophy test in order to graduate and
so you know there was a big demand for
philosophy teachers and that's what she
did she starts teaching and what she
ends up saying and i got in that
interview is i benefitted greatly from
being a teacher that is from being able
to spend a great deal of time reading
writing and educating myself in those
days teacher to teachers didn't have a
very heavy program my studies gave me a
solid foundation because in order to
pass the state exams you had to explore
areas that you wouldn't bother about if
you were only concerned with general
culture then on a personal note i can
say that there's there's really
something to that you know when i when i
did my undergraduate i went to school
where you know it was really a lot of
benign neglect they there was a program
for philosophy but there were very few
of us actually studying it and the
professors weren't particularly engaged
you know or they didn't really pay much
attention to what we're doing so long as
we didn't get in trouble and so you know
I just kind of read whatever I wanted to
read you know I knew what I was supposed
to read and sometimes I'd read it and
sometimes I wouldn't and I could kind of
BS enough to get through my classes if
even if I didn't read the stuff and so
my education was kind of you know
scattershot
and then I went to graduate school and I
was fortunate to go to a place that
although it was low ranked had some
really good teachers and it had a very
rigorous set of examinations that we had
to pay us at the masters and PhD level
that they've long since gotten rid of
because too many students were not doing
well with them and so it caused problems
but those of us who went through that
sort of baptism by by long arduous fire
lasting you know over years where you'd
have this massive reading list and you
had to you know read the stuff that was
on it and
Mariah's large parts of it and then take
exams on it that you'd have to write out
by hand okay that gave me a really good
foundation because they were like she's
saying there's a lot of stuff that I
wouldn't have read otherwise like you
know for example John Dewey you know I I
went to a place where John Dewey there
are a lot of acolytes of him but I
couldn't really stand them and I didn't
like do it but I had to read them in
order to pass those exams and I'm glad
that I did because there were some cool
things and Dewey and you know in other
thinkers as well but then when you start
teaching and you know it's one thing to
be a graduate student right and you're
talking with fellow graduate students
who are also interested in philosophy
and they know your lingo and you can do
kind of shorthand with them verbally you
don't have to like spell everything out
it's a whole other thing to be in a
classroom with a bunch of kids who have
no idea what the hell you're doing
they just know it's it's philosophy and
they're kind of nervous about the class
and they don't really want to be there
and it's up to you to somehow not only
like convince them that it's not all
just crazy nonsense but to get the ideas
across to them without making recourse
to jargon and finding examples that they
can relate to that's where you really
start to learn your subject better and
so I think she's right about that
so she eventually is going to continue
this teaching I do want to bring up one
other thing that that came up in a
biography of hers as well as from Deidre
there she reported that the jury for the
aggregate which is the this this test
that she and jean-paul sartre had to
take they scored first and second in the
test now what's really interesting is
that the jury debated about who they
should give you the first place to and
they gave it to Sartre
now a lot of the people you know think
that they should have given it to do
boudoir
it was Sartre second try
and he was a guy so they you know
decided that he should be the one to get
it but they apparently agreed that she
was the real philosopher compared to him
and she was the youngest Raj at that
time in in French history so she's you
know quite quite brilliant now she she
eventually become that begins teaching
at the Sorbonne in 1941 before that
through this long period while she's
involved with Sartre she meets this
woman Olga
cosa couch who is is essentially one of
she's the person who essentially is one
of the characters in this this first
novel she came to stay which is
published in 1943 which is about a
triangle in 1935 de Beauvoir proposed
that Olga should put herself under her
and starts protection they would pay her
way be responsible for her education and
you know they they actually began an
affair together then you know Sartre
tried to seduce her was as far as I
remember wasn't successful and it became
kind of a scandalous matter around the
same time to de Beauvoir tries to get a
work published there's this when things
of the Spirit come first gets rejected
by press after press and then in 1943
there's a bit of a catastrophe also a
good thing she's right she came to stay
and publishes it but she's suspended
from her teaching position in part
because she's accused of seducing a 17
year old student earlier in 1939 this
had become sort of a part of their mo
Sartre and de Beauvoir de Beauvoir would
would find these these young I guess you
could say kind of impression of
women and then you know start up a
friendship with them and have an affair
and then Sartre would you know he'd come
in on the wings and and hopefully they'd
all be like one big happy family I guess
you could say didn't always turn out
that way but she you know she's accused
essentially of procuring women for
Sartre now if you know if you know
anything about jean-paul Sartre and how
he looked I don't know if you've ever
seen pictures of the guy it was not a
looker the boudoir was start certainly
had personality but you know in terms of
life the sheer attractiveness de pouvoir
was was much more attractive than him
and they had a essentially an open
relationship Sartre proposed what he
called a pact an agreement they could
have Affairs but they were required to
tell each other everything
and he framed it in terms of they have
an essential love but then they could
also experience contingent love affairs
so he's putting it in philosophical
terms which she was quite quite fine
with and you know this this led to these
triangles and there's an interesting
thing by Louima Rahman on in this New
Yorker article he says one theory of
what was going on is clearly wrong that
is the theory that her relationship with
Sartre was a post patriarchal
partnership of equals combining genuine
mutuality with genuine autonomy and
rejecting the superstitious equation of
sexual fidelity with commitment an open
marriage it's now clear that certainty
boudoir did not simply have a long-term
relationship supplemented by independent
affairs with other people the affairs of
other people form the very basis of
their relationship the swapping and
sharing and mimicking the memoir novel
writing right down to the interviews and
published letters and dueling estates
was the stuff and substance of their
marriage that was how they slept with
each other and after they stopped
sleeping with each other the third
parties were in a
this is a really great line prosthesis
marital AIDS so the idea was that
they're using these other people and
their problems and their their you know
whatever they're bringing to the table
as ways to relate to each other you know
and I think that I find that pretty
convincing myself so you know that's
that's an interesting part of their
relationship during the war
Sark's of course was was in the army and
taken as a prisoner of war nothing
really bad happened to him other than
being you know stuck in in barracks he
writes in in notebooks about you know
the worst thing was being bored so it's
not like you know they're gonna execute
him or anything
de Beauvoir ends up working for the the
Vichy government in in a way that drew
some criticism of collaboration
afterwards but what she actually did was
contributed to a radio show you know she
was doing a radio show if I remember
right I have to check my notes for a
second it was on classical music or or
history so you know it's it's yeah
that's right music in the Middle Ages
but you know they would eventually
become part of this this whole
existentialist circle and movement they
they start late Tom more daring modern
times
named after the Chaplin film and the
original editorial board included Sartre
and de Beauvoir but also maurice
merleau-ponty and a number of other
people of Raymond Aron important French
intellectual later on very critical of
the Communists and Sartre said that the
reviews purpose was to publish what they
call literature on gaji which is
committed
writing writing that would would by you
know doing short stories or plays or
novels take stands on things not just
trying to you know depict what happened
by itself but to take a point of view
but to do it in a way that would be not
just sort of like using the characters
as ideological masks for you know
whatever whatever things so they're not
gonna just have the Marxist and you know
the capitalist and the worker or
anything like that they're trying to
depict genuine people within real-life
situations but in an imaginative way
that would have some greater depth to it
or they would take classical themes and
and rework them now de Beauvoir does
that and some of her works one great
example is one of her few plays she only
really writes she only publishes one as
far as I know and it's called the
useless mouths they bouche on util it's
also called who must die because the
central question of it is can't save
everybody who is actually going to die
it takes place in a 14th century Flemish
town under siege and the town revolts
and takes charge of their own destiny
and the people are starving
under the revolt then this this guy Jean
Pierre you know crosses the lines to try
to find with what's going on there's all
sorts of issues getting mixed in there
love taking part in government the point
of the revolt and then they're faced
with a quandary what are they going to
do the burgundy nians are still around
them they only have enough food for some
of the population do they continue their
revolt that you know how's that going to
happen it was everybody gonna die
well maybe we should kill some of the
people maybe we should just withhold
food from those who
and really help and the town council
decides to get rid of the useless mouths
who are the women and children and the
agent so you know and this is to go to
the theme of the history I mean this is
something that is coming out you know
this is written in 1945 around the same
time that the Nazis have been defeated
the Nazis themselves were calling human
beings for over a decade not useless
mouths but life not worthy of life you
know and they they've done that they've
taken the the insane and people with
chronic illnesses and killed them
so you know she's working with some key
ideas she has a few other ones that I
think would be kind of good to mention
as well there's a another work called
the blood of others this takes place
during World War two
there's this guy Jean bloom R who's a
wealthy young man and who leaves his
family and joins the Communist Party and
he meets this woman Helene who is an
individualist living just for the moment
kind of you know kind of a party girl in
some some respect doesn't understand her
his commitment to his beliefs and then
he has to choose he comes to a junction
where he has to decide between his
political commitments and his activism
and his private responsibilities it's
one of these typical dilemmas right and
he realizes that he can he can find his
freedom in his commitments at an action
leaving love behind and so they were
playing around really fundamental
questions that people do in fact face as
time goes on you know Lata mode Aaron
starts out with all these people
involved Raymond Aaron quit by 1900
five in part because late amo Darren
supported communism and around the time
of the Korean War Maurice merleau-ponty
would resign from it as well as a matter
of fact one of the themes that you can
say that characterizes Sartre and de
Beauvoir as a couple not not two not in
the romantic sense now but as like a
partnership in terms of existentialist
thought is it's them against everybody
else sooner or later
another important person who they worked
with was Albert Camus
and pretty soon they you know they break
with him as well over the Algerian war
they always were on each other's side
they always as we say had each other's
backs but their their commitments and
their arguments often distanced them
from from their original collaborators
over time and I think that's you know
kind of common in these sort of intense
partnerships like that so going on she's
you can see she writes quite a few works
she begins travelling in 1947 taking a
five-month trip in the United States and
she starts writing like you know you
could call it travel literature sort of
reflections on what she's seeing in
different places like here so she writes
a book called America day by day you
know and she observes things about like
say the American South and American
segregation and racism and she's very
much a person who's on the side of the
marginalized the oppressed those who are
in many respects less free she's a word
of the important prize the Priya GaN
Corps in 1954 by 1958 there's there you
know things start to fall apart in
France and Charles de Gaulle takes power
and
if you know if you know daddy call he
was a war hero he was the one who led
the Free French you know he also was the
young before the French lost World War
two at the very early part he was one of
the guys who was like saying the right
things and being ignored by the the
French military establishment so he had
a lot of what we nowadays call social
capital right he's somebody who's gonna
be believed and he's you know fairly
right-wing but he's somebody who can
more or less unify the French and he was
able to resolve the Algerian conflict by
actually pulling out whereas the the
Conservatives before that couldn't do
that and nobody could could really
attain some sort of consensus he was
able to use that capital to do that de
Beauvoir begins traveling to a number of
different places around the world
and and again you know sort of checking
out what do things look like on the
ground where you are you know what does
life what the conflicts look like what
does the way in which women are being
treated how are these things play out
she doesn't you know like she isn't just
sort of like right about say Cuba from
reading travel magazines she wants to go
there and see what's actually happening
or you know America or other other
places in the world she writes the
memoirs of a dutiful daughter publishes
that in 1958 her mother doesn't die
until 64 and you know I think you
probably should wait until after cuz
then they can't you know say anything
bad about it right and she's she's
involved in quite a bit of activism you
know she was involved in the manifesto
of the 343 this was a declaration that
was signed by 343 women who admitted to
having abortions which at that time was
illegal you know it's very interesting
this is a bit of a side note about about
abortion
so she talks about this in the second
sex and she she brings it up as an
instance of male hypocrisy that they are
perfectly happy in using abortion as a
form of contraception
you know abortion was technically
illegal and and quite expensive in some
cases in France but it was widely
available
you just had to break the law and so you
know men and women would get together
and the woman gets pregnant and then the
guy is like well you got to do something
about this you know and then oftentimes
they would give them money and
essentially de Beauvoir is saying you
know the way things are set up is
essentially forcing women into positions
of no matter what they do they're
screwed you know complicity with one one
thing or another and since it's men who
are setting up all the rules and then
you know sort of like running the the
game this is really drastically unfair
interestingly one of sart's later novels
in this series that he calls the the
paths of freedom the chemin de la Barthe
in French the very first novel the age
of reason is is about this guy it was
basically Sartre
he's a university professor he's chasing
after these younger female students he's
kind of indecisive about things but he's
living a bohemian lifestyle he's he's
not certain that he's involved with a
woman who he can't stand who he gets
pregnant and then has to figure out you
know where he's gonna get the funds for
an abortion from but that that's the
sort of like the entire preoccupation of
that first novel we've got to get this
woman you know to the abortion so well
they didn't have abortion clinics to the
doctor that they have this done where am
I gonna get the money I'm gonna hit up
my bourgeois brother who tells me I'm
not going to do this for you because you
have to you know reach the age of reason
now
can I find it anywhere else and he's
frantically going around and eventually
what ends up happening is she decides to
keep the baby and the this this
homosexual guy marries her to be what we
nowadays call a beard you know the cover
for that and he's free of his
obligations and he goes back to his with
his life you know and Sartre could write
that kind of novel because he's a guy
you know whereas Simone de Beauvoir you
know she looks at that she's like this
is kind of BS you know what's going on
here so in in 1971 signing this
manifesto this is many years after
they've written these things but signing
that manifesto was a important political
act for her and you know it's only in
1972 that she actually is willing to
call herself a feminist in an interview
she is feminism is kind of a contested
term the second sex comes out in 49 and
we'll talk about that in a bit that was
a very important work but she's not
concerned with being a feminist as such
she's concerned with being an
existentialist who's thinking about
women and their condition and freedom
and responsibility so she's got a
different she's got a different lens
than quite a few other people at the
time 1980 Sartre dies she lives another
six years after that dies of pneumonia
in Paris in 86 you could say you know
that the the very last years of the Cold
War I think we all remember you know at
that time thinking that the Cold War
wasn't coming to an end anytime soon and
then you know 1989 and 90 and 91
happened and the world changed radically
she didn't get to see that her horizons
were brought to a close with you know a
world in which we and the Soviets and
all of our allies are facing off
against each other but very interesting
things are happening in Africa in South
America in Southeast Asia as they
rebuild from the war that the French had
first been involved in
well actually the Japanese and then the
French and then US and she was very
interested in in what was going on in
what you know we talked about the third
world and you know the third world was
an idea that originally didn't just mean
underdeveloped places it was the
non-aligned countries that didn't fit
into the second world of Soviet Union
and Warsaw Pact and the first world of
the United States the NATO allies and
Japan South Korea Australia and whoever
else they wanted to throw in you know
New Zealand I guess so all the the
non-aligned countries and France tried
to play kind of a role in bringing them
together they never did come together as
anything but de Beauvoir was very
interested in liberation movements in in
what was going on politically in other
places and she liked many French people
wanted to find something that wouldn't
just be doing things the the Soviet
Communist way and wouldn't just be like
let's do American capitalism everywhere
you know she was looking for something
something different now I think you can
say that she was very much somebody
living within and swimming within the
history that that was going on at the
time she takes a lot of you could say
timely matters as as her subject matter
for her writings she is deeply concerned
about what sort of progress has been
made or what progress hasn't been made
she was not a believer in the sort of
rhetoric that people use today where
they accuse others of being on the wrong
side of history as if history has some
sort of automatic movement towards
greater and greater freedom
she lived in a time where she saw
freedom contracting if you think about
the 1930s and the rise of fascism and
the spread of all sorts of nationalist
movements and weren't necessarily
fascist but we're also repressive and
what they did to poor people and what
they did to workers and what they did to
women and then you know the entire
colonial sphere the the mid 20th century
was not a time of great freedom as a
matter of fact it was in many ways a
shrinking of it and even in the places
where there was a lot of freedom you
know being sort of protected it was
always kind of selective you know think
about the United States right we
remained a free country
we were devoted to economically a you
know free enterprise system political
freedoms here you know voting took place
there were rival political parties but
you know if you were an African American
living in the south I don't think you
could say you were particularly free or
if you were a worker and and you know
your strike was broken because well the
you know the war machine must go on much
less freedom or if you were a woman in
general there was considerably less
freedom and that I think you know that
was one of the main preoccupations of
her her thought and it fit in well with
the emphasis in existentialism because
existentialism it's hard to define
because you know it's kind of a loose
movement right but one thing that you
can say that they're they're concerned
with across the board is what is the
nature of human freedom when do we have
it and what should we do with it you
know so Sartre talks about that quite a
lot but but she does as well in her
works
so I thought you know one of the things
that would be interesting to discuss but
I get any some passages here from some
of the works how this how's it this
plays itself out I do also want to hit
on the the second sex but she wrote a
book called the ethics of ambiguity it's
a really excellent work jean-paul Sartre
wrote a really big thick book called the
called Being and Nothingness
and you know that one interestingly
there's a bit of a side note that book
was so popular that it actually got used
as sort of a meme or you know symbol of
what it means to like study philosophy
do you remember the movie bro Roxane
with Steve Martin right so the big dumb
fireman who can't speak very well in
that and then you know Martin's
characters got the really long nose he's
supposed to be the cyrano de bergerac
he's a good talker the big dumb fireman
impresses and I forget about the female
lead was it was just some some blonde
was it uh was it Daryl Hannah it was
okay yeah yeah so she sees him going in
the bookstore and he goes hidden against
being a nothingness the philosophy
section and he's up at the counter
buying it and she's like you know are
you reading that and he's like yeah yeah
you know I really like reading this sort
of stuff and he takes it out and he
hands it to that little guy with the
white hair I don't remember the actor's
name and and you know the he was ashamed
to go in and get the book for himself so
he put his big dumb friend up to the
task of doing it but now why was it
being in nothingness because for the you
know the smart set in the 70s and 80s
that was an example of we know that's a
philosophy book and it's a hard
philosophy book right so Sartre was that
successful but one thing he was never
able to do
successfully was developing ethics a way
of you know sort of articulating how we
ought to behave he's got some really
cool analyses in there but he couldn't
pull it off and he admitted it and who
did pull it off de Beauvoir she wrote
this shorter book the ethics of
ambiguity is really quite quite
brilliant and you know she she I've got
a couple passages in here for you so I'm
gonna just read a little bit of this she
says the original scheme of man is
ambiguous that's why it's called the
ethics of ambiguity he wants to be in to
the extent that he coincides with this
wish he fails all the plans in which
this will to be is actualized or
condemned the end circumscribed by these
plans remain mirages human transcendence
is vainly engulfed in those miscarried
attempts but man also wills himself to
be a disclosure of being and if he
coincides with this wish he wins for the
fact is that the world becomes present
by his presence in it but the disclosure
implies a perpetual tension to keep
being at a certain distance to tear
oneself from the world and to a certain
oneself as a freedom and then she goes
out a little bit later she's freedom is
the source from which all significations
and all values spring it's the original
condition of all justification of
existence so we are radically free
that's the existentialist idea we're
free and then we were confronted with
well what the hell am I going to do with
this right and very often were unsettled
by this so we pick up on something I
mean I'm just going to do this that'll
solve everything and that's that's a
free choice you know if I decide that
I'm just a college professor that's a
decision on my part and I often will
conceal that from myself or if I think
oh I'm just a you know a husband or a
father or pick whatever other role we've
got or I'm a good guy or I'm a bad guy
you know these these roles that we take
on we're freely taking them on and we
have we maybe you know there's some that
we're more
interested in than others right we have
some some proclivity towards them like I
could decide I want to be a great
painter but I suck at that sort of thing
and so that's that's probably not going
to happen so it would take an awful lot
of effort for me to lie to myself daily
and say that my my awful paintings are
any good but if I want to think that
like I'm gonna be the next great writer
that's a little bit more feasible that
doesn't take as much biessing of myself
to pull off all right but you know I
could like look at my stuff and say this
isn't really that good maybe I need to
be honest with myself and whether I'm
honest or not that's that's a matter of
freedom as well and when we think about
whether we've solved a problem for good
that's a matter of freedom to a free you
know we think about say personal
problems we have a big argument with
with somebody and our family and now
we've got a beef right and we'll make it
something that's that's you know it's a
sticking point about how to interpret
the past you know what what really went
on in our childhood together were you a
jerk or was I a jerk or were both of us
jerks or is it all the you know there
was the jerkiness of the time or stuff
like that did we ever put this stuff
behind us you said we put it behind us
but I'm still upset about it and that
sort of thing now you can tell yourself
after you have a good heart-to-heart
conversation we've worked everything out
it's all perfect from now on but the
other person can the next time you're
getting together can say no no it's not
solved because they're also a free human
being so we live within a matrix of
other free beings like ourselves and
wouldn't it be a lot more convenient if
they are much more like you know
technology and you know Siri does Siri
does talk back but Siri only talks back
in certain ways and Siri is you know
very humble and effacing what can I do
for you
you know Siri doesn't I mean there's a
few things
programmed in there my kids swear at at
Syria and Syria says that's not very
nice right
but fortunately serious and self-aware
Syrians not actually like combating you
but if you if you're you know if if my
kids went up to human beings and talked
to them the way they do to Siri the
human being would would have a very
different reaction to them and that's
because they're a free entity you know
now our freedom isn't isn't absolute in
the sense that we can all do anything
anytime
any way we want to right it's it's
conditioned by you know physical factors
like I'm you know I'm almost 50 now I
managed to just you know to destroy the
ligaments half the ligaments and one
knee I'm never gonna run again you know
that's okay because I don't need that
bit of freedom it doesn't affect the
other bits of freedom that I'm more
interested in like the freedom to read
and communicate and shoot videos and and
teach or cook my own meals or stuff like
that some people that really would be a
major constraint if your whole identity
is built into being the the middle-aged
athlete who runs marathons well you
probably then would want to get the
operation where they take cadaver
ligaments and stick them in your knee
you know me I don't really need it so
it's not a big priority for me but you
know I thought about this like what if I
were to go blind all the reading I do I
would I could listen to you know books
on CD but there's so much that's not
available that way I'd be screwed you
know that would really affect me in many
ways but then there's all these social
conditions too right
the library is going to close in a
certain amount of time right so I don't
know exactly what time they closed but
they're not gonna let us stay in here
indefinitely they're gonna kick us out
there's certain expectations that we we
live in right a whole network of those
and those those are all products of
other people's freedom and what we do
with it and some of those run very deep
and so did Beauvoir
was analyzing that and saying that's
that's really something that we have to
take his central so now what do we do
with that freedom she sets out a number
of different ways in which people let's
call it misuse they they they don't
recognize their freedom they miss
recognize that they they get rid of it
so they can they can feel more secure
because when you realize that you're
free
well there's responsibility that comes
with that and she starts off by talking
about children when were children one of
the reasons I think a lot of people
would like to go back to their childhood
other people are taking care of things
even if we grew up in a household where
maybe we took on more responsibilities
than then most people too were like
maybe you're cooking when you're six
years old or something like that or
you're you're watching your younger
brothers or sisters because you're the
oldest kid and and you know your parents
are divorced and mom is off at work and
you're in charge or something like that
for the most part you're still within
the world of childhood where other
people are arranging how the world works
and she says we begin as our lives as
children who are dependent on others
this is the human condition and we're
embedded we enter into a world that
already has meanings we don't make it
all up ourselves right and we learn
those meanings and then you know we
figure out how to get by and some people
are not very successful with that they
never quite get the code others very
successful maybe they have temptations
to become manipulative with it because
they realize how easy it is to
understand those things but it's other
people it's other people's world and we
go into it and there's things that are
kind of ready made and there's
established authorities now do we
develop past that or do we remain
children
some people never do some people want to
stay in that groove their entire life
and she calls people like that she's got
two different designations one is she
she talks about the serious person so
they learned some
and it could be they learned them in
childhood or it could be like in
adolescence or it could be they went off
to college and learn these values but
they're convinced that these are these
sets of values that are correct and all
the others are wrong and this provides
the foundation for them and it could be
a political party it could be a
religious standpoint it could be an anti
religious standpoint it could be you
know something like everybody needs to
make this amount of money and it could
be about like you know just social
propriety but there's there's something
that they take as being absolutely
central you know that is what the world
revolves around it could be like you
know competing with your neighbors over
whose Christmas display is faster or
who's a lot is the greatest er whose car
it has the newest there's stuff like
that but what a person does that way is
they avoid taking responsibility for
their freedom because you know they've
got a road map out in front of that she
also talks about what she calls the sub
man and the sub man gets rid of his
freedom by claiming to subordinate to
values which would be unconditioned and
both of these are ways of refusing to
recognize that you're free that it could
be different that you don't have to do
things this way you get to pass the buck
onto somebody else and it could be you
know really horrible stuff like well
I've got a bayonet this guy because he's
the enemy and we all know that's what
you do with with the enemies of the
state or it could just be you know like
well I have to keep going to work you
know because that's what you do you know
not realizing that you can take that out
if you want you could you can say yeah
I'm the kind of guy who likes to you
know go to work and keep doing it
because that's what I'm choosing for
myself that's that's a different stance
than saying oh no I I don't have any
choice it's it's totally you know up to
me or it's human nature or something
like that then there's other types she
says it recognizes their freedom but
they misuse it so she talks about the
knee list
the knee list is the person who believes
in nothing and she says that they failed
that life and so they decide not to try
anything she says they're unable to be
anything so they decide instead of not
being anything to be nothing and they
they they never take a chance they
disparage everything you know the cynics
are like this right people who are
constantly saying things are terrible
and they're always gonna get worse
another possibility is being what she
calls the adventurer this is the person
who throws themself into different life
projects and they're interested in
having a project they're not actually
interested in where they're going these
are the people who say over and over
again it's not the destination it's the
journey right and know the destination
does matter because you know some
journeys are taking us in the wrong
place but but they say oh I'm just I'm
just on my way I'm discovering things
and they don't they don't see that
there's commitments involved there and
they often trample on other people in
the process you know these are the
people who for example get out of their
yoga class and you know say namaste at
the end and then they're you know
flipping everybody off in the parking
lot trying to get out and then she talks
about the passionate person the
passionate person cares about their goal
and they're super enthusiastic about it
but they they show a contempt for for
other people they they they recognize
that they have a project that they're
committing themselves to freely but they
don't recognize other people's freedom
or they they exploit it or they deny it
in some ways she also talks about other
things that that are problematic when it
comes to freedom like the you know the
artist who says I'm just an artist you
know the aesthetic sort of thing where
you step back from everything
I'm not I don't really be involved and
her view is that okay we're free and
other human beings are free but what we
see a lot of the time is that we're not
as free as as we ought to be sometimes
because of other people in pinching on
us sometimes because of our own bad
choices that we've made and we often
place other people in situations where
they're less free as well and what we
ought to be doing if we want to truly be
free ourselves we have to make choices
and this is where it becomes an ethics
and ethics of the ambiguity we have to
make choices that not only make use of
our own freedom
we have to make choices that make other
people more free we have to allow them
to be jet you know genuine agents so you
know this ties in very well with with
her diagnosis of the relations between
men and women and the second sex and you
know she she she thinks that when it
comes down to it women are in a
different position than other people and
in terms of how all things play out
right so that's actually where this this
Hannah women as an other can can be
useful although I see I see a couple PDF
didn't quite print out as it should have
in some places
she talks about women as being the other
to man now this this notion of the other
is not unique to male-female
relationships you can also talk about it
in terms of exploitation where some
people are economically subordinated to
others and they're they're you know
they're not allowed to have like a full
life well whereas the others have a much
more full life because they're they're
you know appropriating the surplus value
or they put people in servitude or
colonialism as a
example of that you can also do it in
terms of ethnicity you know where one
one one whole ethnic group is forced
underneath another through conquest or
slavery or something like that but the
you know she points out that it's
different when it comes to women because
this subordination has always been
around whereas like when it comes to
racial categories I mean the racial
categories that we're working with today
they're pretty new you know and they're
not universal the the census categories
that we have our weird mishmash right
you know we have white or Caucasian we
have black and all it takes to be
considered black or african-american is
the proverbial one drop right which is
the only the only group that's defined
that way we have Native American and
people can check that off on the census
but whether you're actually enrolled in
a tribe is something completely
different
we have Pacific Islander we have this
vast category Asian which covers
everybody from South Asia all the way up
into you know East Asia but doesn't
include Middle Easterners that are
considered white you know so so Iranians
for example they're not Asian enough you
know they're not in the subcontinent and
then we have Hispanic which is you know
more of a linguistic category than
anything else because ethnically well
you know what is Hispanic mean it's it's
a mixing of people of African heritage
Native American heritage and white
heritage and weird combinations and then
when you go to another country like
Brazil our racial categories don't make
any sense there or South Africa or other
places but this this whole notion of
like some somebody being on top whether
it's white Europeans or nowadays and
Asia Han Chinese you know versus the the
we Gers or you know other nationalities
somebody's on top ethnically that
happened in history
it didn't like it wasn't part of our
original condition as far as we can go
back
somebody beat somebody else and
subordinated them and made up some story
about why they're superior and why
they're inferior when it comes to labor
and and capitals so you know that those
things developed over time bosses and
and owners developed historically they
were they didn't exist back in the same
configurations back in the day men and
women there's there's always been this
thing going on and as opposed to like
say you know racial categories or class
categories where people live in
different places they may work together
but they live in different places men
and women live in the same institutions
right so she notices that this is a very
different sort of situation and she she
says one group of human beings imposes
the subordinate status of the other and
another group of human beings and then
you know they don't get to behave as
fully human they're not they're not
getting to participate you could say
within the same structures with the same
status and this is still going on today
I mean you know when I when I open up my
Twitter stream I don't think a single
day goes by without me seeing at least
one woman who I follow on Twitter
complaining about some less qualified
guy mansplaining to them you know if you
think about well what does that mean
that's where you've got some guy who
thinks that because of his his status as
a male he gets to tell a you know woman
PhD in a particular field that because
he read some Wikipedia article she's
wrong about her actual area of expertise
and it goes on constantly you know the
sort of things that de Beauvoir was was
diagnosing in the second sex these these
structures they they replicate
themselves over and over
over again so if you think about it in
terms of existentialism which is what
what she's doing there she's very
interested in thinking of these in terms
of freedom women haven't been treated as
having the same sort of capacities for
freedom as as men historically and it's
in many cases still large right I mean
there's been vast advances in the last
50 years but there's still some glaring
inequities you know my daughter was just
complaining the other day about dress
codes in her high school and how they're
like you know they only apply to girls
there there aren't any problems with
with guys dressing in things that are
sort of the equivalent of what what the
girls get criticized for so there's the
issue of freedom right and then the
question of development and then there's
the question of responsibility who is
allowed to be a responsible agent
unfortunately when when you've got the
other the the responsibility it's kind
of shifted off right onto the whoever's
in the lower position they end up being
more responsible but it's not it's not
being responsible in a full sense
because they're not given the freedom to
do that and this plays itself out you
know in the second sex in terms of men
and women and and you know we could
probably expand and expand this this
analysis today to non-binary people as
well but it also takes place similarly
in all sorts of other settings if we go
back to the ethics of ambiguity one of
the big differences between Sartre and
de beauvoir Sartre hold everybody Radek
you know everything he says everybody
has freedom everybody has the same
amount of freedom everybody is equally
responsible so if you're a schmuck
you've chosen to be a schmuck on some
you know and you're responsible for it
if you're a failed novelist who never
act you know the kind of person who
hangs out in the coffeehouse all day and
has their laptop and they're like yeah
what do you do it I'm working on my
novel you know that's cool can I see a
chapter I don't actually have any
chapters yet I've got an outline and
then you see them like three months
later how's your novel coming oh you
know I now I'm working on short stories
great can I see one of them no I don't
actually have any yet Sartre would say
that person is you know choosing to live
in a situation of false consciousness
and they're they're essentially lying to
themselves about who they are
and they're gonna complain at the end
that they never really had a chance to
you know to be there the great novelist
conditions kept them from doing it and
Sartre says tough you know you you are
what you've made yourself do before is
much more forgiving the further down you
get in and you could say the social
hierarchy if you're on top
she's not gonna cut you much slack at
all you know she's perfectly willing to
say that oh you're rich and you actually
had a good education and you've got all
sorts of resources you're like totally
responsible you know if you're in a
crappy relationship you could be out of
that relationship you could you know you
could change your situation but if
you're growing up in the ghetto and
you're watching people and just every
once in a while beat the crap out of
each other and you've got to watch out
for the cops because you can't trust
them to not arrest you if you bring
things up or give you a hard time
because they're frustrated as hell
themselves and if your school that you
know you've got 40 students packed into
a room and a lot of them misbehaving and
the teacher up in the front just totally
frazzled if you're in a situation like
that you don't have the same kind of
freedom and you don't have the same kind
of responsibility as the person who's up
on top and so she she thinks that no
here's where it gets kind of complicated
when it comes to
your dynamics you you know the ideal is
everybody should be as as free you have
to recognize that they're not and yet
you also have to work towards making
them more free so liberation is a
central part of her ethics you have to
think about is my action that I'm going
to engage in is it a Liberatore action
or does it reinforce conditions and and
structures that keep people on free so
you know a great example of this I've
brought up than me to movement one of
the early issues in that as it was like
spreading all across Twitter is so do
you believe people or don't you believe
people when they report that they've
been sexually harassed or abused or made
out to be uncomfortable or things like
that and there were some people who are
like well I mean unless they can come up
with evidence we should treat it like
any other case let's not believe them
and de Beauvoir would probably say wow
you know you're really expecting a lot
aren't you you know evidence where's
that gonna like pop out of what what box
is that going to be found and of course
you should like believe believe until
you find out that somebody is like full
of crap and then once you know you know
then start you know disbelieving that
person but don't start disbelieving
everybody across the board instead you
should you should try to believe them
and be in solidarity and when you do
that you're creating more space of
freedom because people that are
emboldened to come forward and say yes
this Harvey Weinstein I just take to
take the most egregious example he is a
dirtbag and he did do this to me as well
as this person in this person in this
person and you know we could look at a
lot of different modalities of this you
know we're often faced with situations
where we have to ask is this the right
use of my freedom and how does this
impinge on other people's freedom does
it make them more free does it make them
less free and that's that's the central
front of our ethics it doesn't cover
everything I think but it does get you
quite a bit of what existentialism was
about so she wouldn't hold you know
colonized people except for the elites
as responsible as well-off Americans or
French people but it doesn't mean that
anybody gets off the hook so I've done a
lot of talking we do have some time for
any questions before I talk a little bit
about her you know her own contributions
to history I would say do you have any
questions or comments or my questions is
what she believed in communism oh well
so those are some respect two different
things yeah I mean and you can you can
buy into some of marks without buying
other things so like the notion of
alienation that the way capitalist
workplaces are set up alienates people
from their product from each other from
their own human nature you know I think
she definitely bought into that in a way
you know so part of what it means I
guess to be a communist is not just to
have the diagnosis of you know working
sucks for these reasons and it could be
made better and it should be made better
but it's the how do you make it better
right
and so these I guess you could say to
the extent that she saw
communist or socialist movements as
producing greater freedom she would be
behind them when it comes to like
Stalinist Russia she wouldn't she
wouldn't be
an apologist for that or you know I mean
she got to see the Cuban Revolution
playing itself oh right and the Cuban
Revolution there were good reasons why
they were revolting right but they were
also receiving aid from the Soviets
and once the Castro regime was in they
cut day they cracked down pretty
brutally on dissidents and things like
that so I think you know you could say
that she's she's she's selective in her
endorsement of that and and Sartre is -
you know he doesn't he doesn't just say
well you know you're a communist you're
the good guys you know another thing to
when you're an existentialist you
realize that any movement can go bad
because there's this radical freedom
right so somebody can start out being
you know a man of the people and
liberating everybody and and they can
turn into a corrupt you know person is
just about their own power or vanity or
appropriating resources to themselves
and ignoring the plight of the poor
I mean if communism is going to be any
good it has to always like perpetually
renew its its its gaze towards the
people who are really screwed you know
the people who are really suffering but
you can say you can say similar things
about other political theories you know
it's interesting but we're talking about
this the other day in one of my sessions
about when George Bush George W Bush
came in he came in under this platform
of what he called compassionate
conservative ISM and it was supposed to
be like an alternative to the you know
screw you poor people kind of knee-jerk
and he did try to put into effect some
policies that that actually some of them
just couldn't get through like his
faith-based initiative which was gonna
try to bring churches and other
religious institutions into the position
of like taking care of some social
welfare stuff that probably would have
been a good thing to do he got blocked
because of you know the connection with
religion and then his whole
administration basically got got
themselves off-track and into this this
massive war that's that's devastated the
middle east and produced like a whole
generation of you know soldiers and
marines and and you know other military
people who we now have to take care of
in in many respects some of the policies
that he had were not not you know
terrible policies and many of them seem
to be well oriented but the
administration easily got off track
because it was you know sucked in by
lobbyists and this interest and that
interest and it looks like the the
commitment on the part of many of his
administration was not very deep to that
you know that's another thing too when
you have freedom with with freedom
oriented towards genuine human values
like say solidarity with the poor there
has to be a deep commitment and the fact
that we're free means that we can
abandon that commitment at any point
when it's convenient to us you know and
we have to like recommit over and over
and over again when it gets tough and i
think a lot of people just whether you
know no matter what political ideology
you look at or what religious
institution you look at or educational
institutions and at any moment anybody
can abandon their post you know what's
what's keeping them there they're their
own commitment to keep following through
okay well how about religion yeah
I think she was easy she was an atheist
yeah which should be against religious I
mean because they're helping the
downtrodden you know well that's a good
ones but they pretty controlling I mean
they they definitely want you to stay in
the religion yeah I think it'd be kind
of a case-by-case thing children to be
brought up in the religion
yeah so I could see pluses and minuses
from her perspective
yeah insofar as religion is used as a
mode of social control and part of that
control is like other values besides the
religion like you know be nice be a good
productive member of society sometimes
there's like political alignments like
you know if you're this you have to vote
this way and if you're this you vote
that way and then there's like you said
the other part of control keep keep
going into the the religious stuff if
you don't go to church every Sunday
you're a bad XYZ or Moscow temple
whatever happens to be make sure you tie
there you know you know the pain of the
bishops fund or things like that and
then you know of course there's the
hierarchy as well usually within most
religious groups even if they don't have
an official hierarchy there's usually
somebody who like is is the authority
right and so I think she would say that
insofar as religion is pushing that it
would be bad right but I mean it's also
up to us to not like to say well you
know I was raised that way and so I had
to go along with it I mean she would say
no I don't I don't buy that excuse like
think about you know one of that one of
the the like ever renewed scandals
within the Catholic Church it never
seems to get any better or go away as
the sexual abuse scandal I mean decades
now of like new revelations and new
revelations about the cover-ups that
were going on and sometimes it's tied in
with other things too like you know
spending money on the wrong thing
you know all these these luxuries and
you know I don't think she would she
would accept for a second anybody's
saying oh well you know the priest told
me it was okay so I went along with it
or you know I think she had some no
different with children I think if she
would say if you had a child is being
abused and they don't know what's you
know what's water who's who and they are
being told by the religious authorities
this is what what God wants for you and
their parents are like keep it quiet or
something like that she would treat them
as as children see well they don't have
much responsibility but by the time they
get to be like 20 and are starting to
discover these things for psychotherapy
or things like that I think she'd say no
you you you have to like take
responsibility for yourself even though
it sucks even though this is not stuff
you'd want to look at and you have to
like you know stare reality in the face
and say maybe I don't want to be
affiliated with this this this group
anymore I have to find my own path but
she also I also don't think she'd like
being cool with people who like to swing
way to the other extreme and are like
Crusaders for atheism just because they
left their conservative church
upbringing you know that's that's just
another way of like being what she calls
the serious person you find a set of
values you think that they solve
everything and you don't have to think
about anything anymore but again that
can happen with with economic systems
with political systems you know it can
happen with with philosophy you know you
could you could be one of these if we
could just be clear about terms you know
and and like you police everybody's
language if we could just do that then
all the human conflicts would go away
and she would say well you've got to be
you've got to be wary of committing
yourself to those sorts of things as if
they're gonna solve everything
you know one of the things she got
criticized for was not having strong
women in in you know sort of like in her
novels and things like that and she said
I'm more interested in people who are
actually like facing real life
challenges not on these pasteboard
characters who exemplify some sort of
ideals I want to actually like write
characters who screw up and I mean I'm
just roughly paraphrasing here right but
but who face real challenges and
sometimes measure up to them and
sometimes don't and sometimes feel
regret because those are that's where we
actually you know make our choices it's
not the choices are never like should I
do good or should I do evil first let's
dark is that it's like usually like
should I do this good that comes with
some evil or this kind of good that also
comes with evil but might be more good
maybe I don't know some people are
saying this is better and the more that
I look at it though I think I probably
should do this it's it's usually stuff
like that you know so yeah it was a very
long answer to the question I think yeah
do you have any questions
oh well I've been reading her for a long
time so yeah you know I first I first
encountered her in undergraduate I
mentioned that like I I just read
whatever the hell I wanted hey I got her
ethics of ambiguity at a used bookstore
down here actually I was up in in
Sheboygan at Lakeland College but I'd
come down here to go to Half Price Books
you know and somebody must have been
teaching it or something like that so
they were there a bunch of copies I
bought one and I was like this is really
good stuff you know the other stuff I
read much later you know like the second
Saks
some of her novels and should we burned
Assad so yeah do you find it to be
complete oh that's a good question when
the holes beat so by the very nature of
her philosophical position were supposed
to take account of the situations that
we're in sort of overarching situations
and you know like we such died in 86 so
she did not get to see the new world
order to use George you know George
Herbert Walker Bush is phrase that we
effectively live in where the United
States is what the French called the
hyper power for at least the time being
and all sorts of other interesting
things happened she didn't get to see
that sort of stuff so she didn't get to
write about that and we can extrapolate
you know what would she say about this
development or this development but we
don't actually have her saying that
about that right I think that you know
that I mean there's there's criticisms
of her by other later feminists for not
having taken adequate account of things
that they think are particularly
important and there are criticisms of
her her behavior with Sartre you know
she's all about freedom it seems like
she behaved in manipulative ways with
some of these young women that that they
drew in although you know they're there
they were they were also like her and
Sartre and you know her being involved
with with some other guys too so you
know is was she entirely consistent no
but I don't think she you know I don't
think she has to be entirely consistent
there's enough of a framework that you
could
- yeah changing world yeah do you think
most academics whatever reading would
would be able to come to something of a
consensus and how she would apply oh
that's good that's another good question
- the new like you know what would what
would her views on say dating be like in
2019 when we have apps and people are
you know there's there's a lot more
equality but it's not it's not like full
equality in many respects yeah I think
there's probably there's there's not
like a hundred percent consensus among
academics you never find that oh yeah
but I think you could say there's like
there's probably like a critical mass of
people who use her thought that would be
an agreement and then there'd be
outliers on this side or outliers on
this side and and maybe some of the
outliers are not as good or reliable
interpreters of her yeah I mean she's
very much about responsibility the more
freedom you have the more responsibility
you also bear she doesn't accept excuses
one thing that she said that was really
interesting in the second sex was that
she did not she talked about male and
female inferiority and equality and I
know they're gonna kick us out soon so
there's a good thing to have done she
said you know generally it's been you
know male superiority made the female
inferiority some people want to reverse
it so that it's like female superiority
male inferiority others are like strict
equality is what we need and then she's
like I don't want any of these things
and that need to be what do you actually
want that I want people to like actually
be accountable for themselves and relate
to each other as human beings and not
need some sort of structure where
they're like well we're all equal now
you know because because it's never
totally equal or you know think that one
sex is automatically superior and one is
inferior in some respects she's she's
like another important feminist author
who also got a bad rap because she lived
a rather an unusual lifestyle that's
Mary Wollstonecraft from the the 18th
century
Wollstonecraft diagnosed some of the
same things that de Beauvoir is
diagnosing these cuts herself with
self-reinforcing cycles where women are
not given the same opportunities to
develop and therefore they're not
performing but like men do in situations
and then that's the evidence for why we
shouldn't give them any opportunities
right same thing that that's often done
for with with racial minorities or with
lower classes and stuff like that it's
it's an old trick and we'll Stone Kraft
says we got to break this cycle but we
should also hold everybody totally
responsible so women don't automatically
get a pass for everything just because
they're stuck in this this you know
cycle as a matter of fact the the really
bad thing about it is they've got a
false consciousness about you know how
they ought to behave men and women both
need to be way more as Wollstonecraft
says more virtuous than they are which
means they need to develop their human
capacities fully de Beauvoir doesn't
like language of virtue of course
because that was kind of moralistic at
the time but she would say men and women
both need to as individuals use their
freedom to develop themselves fully and
I think she thought that most people
don't do that of either gender so yeah
so she rejected you know replacing
inferiority and superiority with with
equality and she said that's that's
that's a mistaken way of looking at the
situation and I think she's right about
that so long as it just doesn't turn
into like a well I'm just gonna like
stick in my own little area over here as
well Terry said we have to cultivate
our garden you know the the thing that
goes well screw everybody else's guards
you know the other stuff doesn't matter
she thought we need to be we need to be
engaged which means were probably never
really gonna be happy because there's
always you know more stuff that's
screwed up trust
[Music]
you